i just listen everybody know i like the  gamble  i want to be dead broke when i kill  overfill i don't want to leave all that  money for my freeloading family  i've been taking care of my whole life i  want to be dead broke at my last breath  brooke she got the memories and i just  listen everybody know i like the gamble  i want to be dead broke when i kill  overfill i don't want to leave all that  money for my freeloading family  i've been taking care of my whole life i  want to be dead broke at my last breath  brooke she got the memories and i just  listen everybody know i like the gamble  i want to be dead broke when i kill  overfill i don't want to leave all that  money for my freeloading family  i've been taking care of my whole life i  want to be dead broke at my last breath  brooke she got the memory